Ukrainian ambassador to the UK van
impristaiko hello to you Mr Ambassador
thank you for joining us what did you
make of this morning's events
no I actually feel sorry for Russians
but they're still going through the same
the same repetition
of this lies in propaganda and sooner or
later they will have to open up their
minds and see the reality and the
reality is that the only Nazi state is
Russia right now the only criminal
leader is Russian leader now and they
can have this you know can they allow
people closer to the the Machinery the
military machine because most of the in
Ukraine already in this stage where you
can actually see how strong and how good
the equipment is he had many
um leaders State leaders by his side
offering him support today
not that many as he used to have and
very unfortunately he doesn't have
anybody who was on his side at the time
of War this is just remnants of Soviet
Union and don't forget that we were they
were the biggest part of it and we
suffered with Bill Russians the most I'm
really sorry to say look schenka there
but that's that's reality right I'm
surprised were you that the Belarusian
leader Alexander lukashenko was there
I'm not I'm not surprised I I'm I I'm
sorry that he's here and his Nation
proportionally lost the most out of all
the nations in the world because it was
occupied like Ukraine as well Russia not
and all this
they don't know what is the atrocities
of Nazis they don't have the personal
personal sort of experience
yeah but what he's doing is hedging his
bets because he doesn't necessarily
think that you guys are going to win the
war
that's what he has to do you know he has
to bring it up in the Russian media he
has to bring it up within his own people
he has to mobilize his people for
another wave of this you know thousands
of young men and women coming to all to
fight and die so that he is doing his
job the one problem is that he's not
winning we are
we've seen a significant number of
missiles launched in your general
direction your country's general
direction over the weekend people have
died
civilians I should say Obviously sadly
people on the battlefield dying all the
time but civilians have died this is
interesting you're right when you send
in the Secretary of Victory our common
Victory sending Rockets against one of
your allies in the closed Nation
brothers and sisters yes you're right
but with your assistance we managed to
kill 26 our 28 Rock has been sent this
this day and the day before 35 out of
35. so we are trying our best to protect
our civilians and we're actually
achieving a great great success so you
don't need uh um fighter jets when you
fight the Jets because we can't reach
those ones uh these the planes which are
sending bombs from the Russian territory
they are safely hiding you know behind
the the official border and the
launching the Rockets this is how big
this problem we can't do much against
these dumb drums the bombs being updated
to Glide a bit 50 kilometers 60
kilometers to the nearest towns this is
the biggest challenge right now why did
Ukraine try to assassinate President
Putin last week did not he says he did
yeah no he's saying many things
who do you think did I don't believe
that this is the way to how to
assassinate somebody in a in a bunker
and we know how to build bunkers look at
it we have bunkers in Ukraine I had my
Ministry of Foreign Affairs deep bunker
even nuclear you can withstand the
nuclear strike you also need one drone
against huge building in Kremlin to kill
somebody I believe the assistance to you
know to raise
to mobilize people just before the the
eights or nines of May whatever he is
celebrating
the grain deal
green dealers is needed to not to us
that much but to hundreds of millions of
people around the globe who believe they
are feeding around 400 million people
mostly in Africa Asia and Latin America
and put in his plane because he's
telling them that because of the of the
west of the science sanctions against
Russian grain they can have bread on
their plate which is not true we have in
abundance that that's why they're not
alive and they're waiting until price
will rise so he will cover some of the
losses from the sanctions as well so
what needs to happen in order for the
grant hill to continue on as we know I'm
just looking at pictures of Odessa and
you can see on the screen as we're
talking see and that is the port that
much of the grain would go through
um if that grain does not get to
countries particularly in Africa people
will starve what can you do to make it
happen first of all people will starve
then we don't have stories where to put
the new new Harvest and will come we are
exporting a level of close to 100
million tons this is lots and lots of
grains you have to put it somewhere so
he understands that that's why he is
cutting this you know deal what to what
have to happen easiest ways that we win
and restore the normality in the in the
trade around the globe and the political
life but it's not happening anytime soon
so what we have to do we have to find
other ways like that we have to call
them uh dry ports which is more or less
the other ways of exporting
through the trains through the products
every anywhere near enough but we'll
need another four years to you know if
we replace the the by trains these ships
great ships
I understand that what we're trying to
achieve right now we're trying to
negotiate with the help of Turks and un
it's not working perfectly each and
every time but this is important that's
why we're still in these negotiations
um what's happening to your spring
offensive we were promised it and we
don't seem to have seen much of it
that's because we are not Russian we are
trying to prepare ourselves we've been
just a couple of days ago with my
premise and first lady seen how you are
helping our soldiers to be prepared
better we wanted to survive this not
just throw them in this meat grinder we
were seeing the Australian new
zealanders training without people this
is great help we are receiving more and
more sophisticated weapons we're trying
how to you know training how to use them
correctly we need some things which were
quite open with we need f16s or whatever
the planes are and we need long reaching
artillery or Rockets Russia would say
you're talking the talk and not walking
the walk they can say whatever they want
and they can prepare themselves we see
there are people fleeing from the from
the front lines because they expect in
our country offensive we're not going to
tell them when and where because we have
a thousand kilometers of front lines but
there are a couple of directions they
understand already the Crimean Peninsula
the Crimean land bridge is obvious
destination for our troops is it coming
the offensive yes
some people already argue that we
already started it's just not seen on TV
yet because of this massive massive
drone attacks massive rocket attacks
that's what's already been happening
when do you expect the conflict in your
country to end
there are different expectations and
some people believe that it won't happen
until the this year or somebody said
this next year the important part that
we prepare for this is not easy believe
me financially and we're losing people's
lives and in the cities and economy is
going we at least lost a third of all
our economy and everything eight million
of us outside of the nation but we're
fighting and we believe they will get
get to the point when they will break
and we'll get back to Russia we don't
want to chase them down they can do
whatever they want on their own
territory not on ours
looking at the Victory Day Parade
finally in where we started um today
there is much resolution amongst those
young men who want to come and fight you
listen I remember myself I was 21 years
old when sodium collapsed I was watching
TV the same way and expecting that all
of us will go and die against the
capitalists in our last fight all of
this stuff that's what happens when you
after 70 80 90 years old are still
living at the same part and the Soviet
Union collapsed we ukrainians start to
understand open up for the world and
understood who were fighting with whom
what was the tragedy of German people
was treated of all of us so the complex
picture is now in our heads much more
complex than the Russians they still
live in this previous Century life
must leave it there Mr Ambassador it's
always a pleasure thank you very much
thank you for joining us on the program